PROFESSOR: Hi.
Welcome to recitation.
My name is Martina, and I'll
be your recitation instructor
for some of these
linear algebra videos.
Today's problem is
a straightforward
solve the following
linear system
with four equations
and four unknowns,
using the method of elimination.
The system is x minus y minus
z plus u equals 0, 2x plus 2z
equals 8, minus y
minus 2z equals -8,
and 3x minus 3y minus
2z plus 4u equals 7.
And although you might
know different ways
to solve the system
at this point,
the method of
elimination is going
to show up a million
times during these videos,
so it's really important
to get it right.
So I suggest you try solving
this system now, using
the method of elimination as
it was described in class.
I'm going to leave you
alone with the problem.
You should pause the
video, solve it yourself,
and then come back and compare
your solution with mine.
And we're back.
So the method of elimination,
if you remember it from class,
consisted of replacing this
system with an equivalent
system-- equivalent meaning
they have the same solution--
by a series of row operations.
Row operations are not
supposed to change the solution
to the system.
And they're, for
example, exchange
the order of two equations.
Multiply an equation
with a nonzero number,
and add a nonzero multiple
of one equation to the other.
So let's do that.
As we're going to do this
series of arithmetic operations,
we don't really want
to copy the names
of the variables and the
equality signs every time.
So we're going to keep the
important information which
are these numbers.
these coefficients
here, we're going
to keep that
information in a matrix.
So let's write a matrix.
Each row is going to
correspond to an equation,
and each column is going to
correspond to an unknown.
So the first row
is 1, -1, -1, 1.
The second row, corresponding
to the second equation,
is 2, 0, 2, 0.
And you want to be very careful
to put 0's on the right spots
here.
The third equation is
0-- I haven't left myself
enough room-- 0, -1, -2, 0.
And the fourth
row, corresponding
to the fourth equation,
is 3, -3, -2, 4.
And as we care about the
right-hand side as well,
we're going to copy this
information as well,
and get the augmented
matrix of the system.
0, 8, -8, 7.
OK, and now let's try
reducing this matrix
to an upper triangular one.
We start with the
first column, and we're
going to use this
number, called a pivot,
to get rid of all
the numbers under it,
so to get 0's here and here.
A way to do it is-- well,
to get rid of this 2,
I have to multiply
the first row by -2,
and add it to the second one.
Writing this here is
not strictly necessary,
but I like to do a
bit of bookkeeping,
because I'm prone to
make a lot of errors
while doing this simple
arithmetic operations.
And then if I get
to the end, figure
out I made a mistake
somewhere, this bookkeeping
makes it easier to
backtrack and find the place
where I made this mistake.
So we replace this matrix
with another matrix.
The first row stays the same.
1, -1, -1, 1, 0.
The second row gets replaced
by the second row minus 2 times
the first row.
The aim of that is to get
a 0 here, so that's good.
Next, on this position
here, we get -2 times -1,
which is 2, plus 0 which is 2.
-1 times -2, which is
2, plus 2, which is 4.
-2 plus 0 which is -2.
And 8 minus 2
times 0 which is 8.
The third row
already has a 0 here,
so I can just copy it over.
0, -1, -2, 0, -8.
And to get a 0 here, I'm going
to multiply the first row by -3
and add it to the fourth row
and get 0, -3 times -1 is 3,
minus 3 is 0.
-3 minus 1-- oh, sorry-- 3 minus
2 is 1, and -3 plus 4 is 1.
And there we go.
The first column looks
like a first column
of an upper triangular matrix.
Now let's do the same
to the second column.
This is going to be our
pivot, the number that we use
to get rid of numbers under it.
And we see that to
get rid of this number
here, we will need to
multiply it with 1/2.
So multiply the whole
second row with 1/2,
and add it to the third row.
The matrix that we get will
have the first row the same.
It stays the same.
1, -1, -1, 1, 0.
The second row stays the same.
0, 2, 4, -2, 8.
The third row gets
replaced by the third row
plus 1/2 times the second row
and becomes 0, 0, 2 minus 2
which is 0, -1 plus 0 which is
-1, and 4 minus 8 which is -4.
And the fourth row already has
a 0 here so I just copy it over.
0, 0, 1, 1, 7.
And now let's look
at this matrix.
It has the first two columns
as they're supposed to be,
0's under the diagonal.
And now we want to get a 0 here.
Normally what I would do is
to circle this number here,
multiply it by something
so that I get a -1,
and add it to this
row to get a 0 here.
But that's not going to work.
You might remember from lecture
that 0's can never be pivots.
Or you can just try finding
a number such that 0
times this number
equals -1, and seeing
that such a number
doesn't exist,
because you're always
going to get 0.
So we can proceed
as we did until now.
But is there another
way to get a 0 here?
There is a very
simple row operation,
which consists just of switching
the third and the fourth row.
It certainly doesn't change
the solution of the system.
So let's do that.
And let's get the next matrix
which is 1, -1, -1, 1, 0.
0, 2, 4, -2, 8.
Then we put the fourth row here.
0, 0, 1, 1, 7.
And we put the third row
here, 0, 0, 0, -1, -4.
And there it is.
This is an upper
triangular matrix.
So in the same way as at the
beginning, we had a system
and then wrote the
matrix representing it,
this matrix also
represents a system.
And this system has the same
solutions as the initial system
but is much easier to solve.
Now let's write this
back as a system,
and let me do that not starting
from the first equation,
but starting from
the last equation.
So the last equation
here reads -u
equals -4, which
is, as equations go,
a pretty easy one to solve.
The solution is u equals 4.
Now let's go back to
the third equation.
The third equation
reads y-- no, I'm
sorry-- z-- the third column
corresponds to z-- plus u
equals 7.
But we know what's u now.
So, it reads z plus 4 equals 7,
which just becomes z equals 3.
The second equation is 2
times y plus 4 times z,
but z is 3, minus 2 times
u, but u is 4, equals 8.
And from this, one can easily
compute that y is equal to 2.
And finally, the first equation
reads x minus y minus z plus u
equals 0, or x equals 1.
And this is our solution.
x, y, z, and u equal
1, 2, 3, and 4.
This finishes the problem,
but I would very strongly
encourage you now to
take this solution
and plug it back into
the original system
and check if it's
really a solution.
And that's all I
wanted to say today.